I'm very pleased to announce that our first speaker tonight at our intelligence
squared online plus first speaker for the motion is Medhi Hassan.
He is a veteran of intelligence where it, of course, journalists and broadcast.
He's the host of up-front and head-to-head on Al-Jazeera English.
He's also a columnist for the intercept and a contributing editor
for the new statesman. Many hats on the floor is yours.
Thank you, Liz. Uh, ladies and gentlemen, this is a debate. So before you vote,
let's be clear what you're voting for, what this debate is actually about,
because we will hear a lot from the opposition today about Iran's awful human
rights record its lack of democracy, its sponsorship of terrorism and extremism.
It's support for the brutal Asad regime in Syria.
And I'm not here to dispute any of those things.
Iran has a lot to answer for I'm no fan of the Uranian government,
but that's not what we're here to debate today. Whether Iran is good or bad. No,
we here to debate very specifically whether Iran is our enemy,
not our adversary, not our arrival, not our opponent, but our enemy.
An enemy has a very specific meaning enemies on just those you compete with or
argue with their people. You have to hate, you have to want to fight.
You have to eventually try and destroy. Is that really what we want another war?
And does Iran even fit the definition of a real enemy?
Here are three very simple reasons in my view,
why Iran doesn't fit that definition and why you should support this motion? Uh,
tonight number one, um,
Iran is not our enemy because it's a strange sort of enemy that has worked with
the West to fight the West West enemies, often nine 11.
It was Iran that helped the U S and UK topple the Taliban in Afghanistan and the
Al Qaeda presence in that country in 2016 and 2017,
it was Iranian backed militias that helped the U S and UK defeat ISIS in Iraq.
They were the much needed ground troops. Number two,
Roman has done our enemy because it's a strange sort of enemy that spent two
years negotiating with us to limit its own nuclear program, uh,
that signed at historic unprecedented 159 page diplomatic agreements
in which they publicly pledged quote under no circumstances,
will Iran ever seek, develop or acquire any nuclear weapons.
And then according to every independent expert, every IAEA report,
they stuck to the terms of that deal. They did not break that deal. In fact,
it was the United States on the Donald Trump that walked away from that violated
that historic nuclear agreement. Number three,
Iran is not our enemy because if the opposition want you to believe that
sponsoring terrorism, fermenting, extremism,
denying democracy to your people automatically makes you an enemy of the West.
Then what on earth does that make Saudi Arabia?
I can't wait to hear some on the sorry,
speech for the opposition on behalf of the Saudis today because it wasn't 15
Iranians were on those planes on nine. It was 15 Saudis.
It wasn't a Iranian school curriculum that ice is borrowed from in Rocca.
It was the Saudi school curriculum.
It wasn't an Al Qaeda sponsored Iranian cadets who just six months ago,
shot and killed three U S Navy sailors at a military base in Florida.
It was an Al-Qaeda sponsor, Saudi cadet. And yet, despite all of this,
we're perfectly okay saying Saudi Arabia is not only not our enemy,
but it's our ally,
our friend BFF in the region while Iran is our mortal enemy.
Sorry. How does any of that make any sense? Uh, whatsoever?
Let me be very clear. Iran has done a lot of that. I think it has,
but try and put yourselves in Iranian shoes because the UK and us have done bad
things to Iran too.
They helped overthrow a democratically elected or Indian government in a coup in
1953. They helped Saddam Hussein's Iraq, uh,
kill hundreds of thousands of Iranians during the Iran, Iraq war in the 1980s,
including with poison gas,
the U S also shut down in Iranian civilian airliner in 1988,
killing 290 people on boat and never apologized. Now, of course,
many in Iran, the hardliners,
the extremists like our own hotline is an extremist.
John Bolton want us to be enemies with them forever.
They want a war at some point, but I'm not here to, to defend those hob liners,
all that rhetoric of, you know,
the great Satan and death to America and flat burning. It's done.
It's unhelpful. It's undeniably hostile and belligerent. I get that,
but we're not kids in a playground.
The point is not for us to respond with more hostility,
more belligerents more provocations, more deadly economic sanctions in return.
No, the point is to ratchet down tensions in the region to deescalate,
to strengthen diplomatic and economic ties and use things like trade,
which I often hear my good friend, Daniel Hannon, extol,
the virtues to transform hostility into harmony,
to promote democracy and freedom in Iran, not more paranoia and dictatorship,
and to do all of that by voting full by endorsing this motion,
our motion today.
But I will say this. It's strange to see Daniel Hannan on the opposition side,
Daniel who opposed George bushes invasion of Iraq,
who opposed Barack Obama's war in Libya now pushing for Donald Trump and his
deranged cohorts to attack it wrong. The mind Buggles.
This is what Daniel wrote in January about the Uranians and I quote,
they need to be confronted and defeated. That's a call for war.
It is. Is that really what you want to vote for today?
Another trillion dollar disastrous,
illegal middle East war that kills tens of thousands.
If not hundreds of thousands of innocent people. I mean,
don't forget a war with Iran would make the war with a look like a walk in the
park. And one final point before I wrap up,
think about the wording of this motion. Iran is not our enemy. Who is the ally?
Who is the implied wheat? Is it Saudi Arabia? Is it the UAE?
Is it Israel? Because it won't probably is an enemy of Saudi Arabia of Israel,
of the UA, but come on it poses no actual strategic.
It's not an enemy to the people of Europe or the U S several thousand miles away
from the U S or at least it shouldn't be treated as an enemy by us.
If you think it's an enemy of Saturday to fight, vote for them,
vote against the motion, but it's not an enemy of ours. I, for one,
I'm fed up with conflating,
the interests of foreign governments with those of our own iPhone,
I'm fed up with Western countries,
taking sides in the middle East regional conflict that we should really have
nothing to do with audio.
For one I'm fed up with the never ending Wars that the U S and the UK keep
starting in the middle East. And with those irresponsible people,
the unthinking holes who keep pushing for those attacks,
there should not be a war with Iran. There cannot be a war with Iran.
Iran is many, many things, but it is clearly not our enemy.
So I begged to propose this motion. Thank you very much for your time.
Thank you very much. Thank you very much. Maybe Hassan for.